- Hey guys, it's Inga.
Today, we're gonna be doing something
a little bit different.
My friend Ade gave me an ostrich egg.
Ta-da!
He challenged me to make
a giant Egg McMuffin.
(laughing nervously)
We only have one ostrich egg.
It is not a cheap egg.
The stakes are very high,
but let's make it work.
We're gonna start off by
making the English muffin part.
So I looked up some recipes,
and I made the dough last night.
(whimsical big band music)
So here's the dough.
Flour, moment of truth.
Oh, ho!
Look at how much air this has.
I'm gonna knead this gently.
Ooh.
It's so smooth.
(whimsical big band music)
I need to roll this out.
- [Man] You gotta do that.
- Gotta roll it.
Like pizza.
(light jazzy music)
That looks pretty decent.
They said sprinkle pretty generously.
I think I'm being very generous.
It smells so good.
And we're gonna cut it.
Ooh la la.
Now this is what it looks like right now.
This is the muffin.
(giggling)
(clattering)
We're gonna let this prove
for a little over an hour.
We can start working on the ostrich egg.
Dun-dun-dun.
You hear that?
Like a china plate.
Very smooth.
Even though it has bigger pores than I do.
(clinking repeatedly)
(gasping)
(clattering)
It's beginning to crack.
(clinking repeatedly)
(light jazzy music)
Oh my God.
The membrane!
Why is it so full?
Ah!
I don't know what to do.
Oh.
(light jazzy music.
- [Man] It's gonna be
a crunchy Egg McMuffin.
- Oh!
I'm shaking.
(gasping)
(light jazzy music)
Ta-da!
It looks like egg?
That was the hardest part.
I'm gonna pour this in the mold now.
(laughing)
I'm gonna put it in the oven, okay?
Oh my God, it's leaking.
Oh my God.
(big band music)
We're gonna go with 350.
Make it a little lower.
Okay, let's check on that later.
We're going to transfer
this huge piece of bread
to the cast iron.
How does one transfer this?
Ah.
No, no, no, flip it.
(laughing)
Wow, that was a complete
and utter failure.
We're just gonna wait now,
until it becomes golden brown.
(light jazzy music)
I think it's about that time.
Look at it!
Yay!
Wow.
Wah!
Put it on this heated baking sheet.
(light jazzy music)
I'll put it in the oven.
Bye-bye.
See you later.
It's all coming together now.
Beautiful ostrich egg.
I'm so excited.
(clanging)
So while I'm waiting
for these to cool down,
I am going to pan fry
these super thick cut,
by thick, I mean, damn, this is thick.
Check it out!
Perfect for a giant Egg McMuffin.
(sizzling)
Huh!
Okay, so you're only supposed
to open these with a fork,
so I found a giant fork-ish thing.
Let's try.
(light jazzy music)
Ooh.
(mimicking fanfare)
English muffin!
I'm so happy!
So we're gonna butter these slices up,
make it extra greasy, extra yummy.
Hey, hey.
And these are going back in the oven.
So we're gonna do the
most important part now.
For research purposes,
the original Egg McMuffin.
You see the bread on top,
the ham, the egg, the cheese.
So that's how we're gonna build ours.
Here we go.
Ta-da.
I could not find a giant piece of cheese,
so we're gonna have to do this one by one.
This is the moment we've been waiting for.
(imitating fanfare)
Wow, how do you take this off?
Whoa!
Now we're gonna put the ham.
Ta-da!
And we're gonna cover it up.
And this, my friends, is the beautiful,
giant Egg McMuffin.
The only thing missing is
that we need to get the cheese
just like this, super melty.
Dun-dun-dun.
Wow!
Original one.
It looks kinda alike, right?
(laughing)
Wow, guys.
I did it.
I didn't think I would be
able to do it, but I did it.
The real test is does it taste like it?
We don't know.
I'm gonna have my friends and
my coworkers reveal the truth.
I'm nervous.
(jazzy big band music)
(group gasping and ah-ing)
- Oh, yes.
This thing itself is the
size of an Egg McMuffin.
(whimsical big band music)
It tastes exactly like an Egg McMuffin.
- Yay!
(whimsical big band music)
Yay, I did it!
Until next time.
Bye-bye.
(whimsical big band music)
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new channel.
And now your part.
- Subscribe here.
- That was my part.